Amy, you're my best friend.
We do everything together.
We love to have
tea parties.
And dance parties.
(woman)
Get ready for a day
of fun and glamour
when you're hanging out
with Amy,
the official
Amy Schumer doll.
Look, she's spicing up
her coffee.
Glamorous.
(alarm clock ringing)
1:00 P.M.! We're allowed
to wake her up now.
She's waking up in a
stranger's bed again.
She's so popular.
(record skipping)
Uh-oh.
No wrappers on
the floor.
Time for Plan B.
Amy comes complete with a
variety of accessories,
including a purse
for her essentials
that you can dump
on the table.
What's in your
purse, Amy?
Birth control, Lexapro,
dusty candy corn,
and a business card
from a Tekserve employee
that gave her a vibe.
Amy also comes with a six-pack
of cranberry juice
to help her UTI.
You'll feel better
soon, Amy.
Dress her in three
different outfits
that hide
her problem areas:
a crop top...
This shows off
her tramp stamp.
...skinny jeans
to keep in the closet...
For someday.
...and one nice thing
for court.
(gavel bangs)
(girls laughing)
It's okay, Amy,
you can fall asleep
in your clothes again.
Don't forget
to sleep on your side.
(Amy retching)
It's Amy,
the official Amy Schumer doll
from the makers
of Fat Babs.